ذهب الابتكار والتنقل إلى ما هو أبعد
من وسائط النقل النموذجية في CES
، وظهرت كيف يمكن للتقنيات المختلفة
أن تتفاعل مع الواقع الافتراضي
كموضوع رئيسي
، قد يكون metaverse معروفًا في الوقت الحالي
كمساحة للألعاب
وسماعات الواقع الافتراضي ولكن صانع سيارة كوري واحد
كشفت النقاب عن مفهوم جديد للتنقل الفوقي ،
وهو مستقبل تفاعلي وافتراضي جزئيًا
حيث يتفاعل البشر
مع الروبوتات للتنقل للقيام
بمهام مختلفة عن بُعد وأتمتة
شركة هيونداي موتور ، وهي أكبر
شركة لصناعة السيارات في كوريا الجنوبية ، تقوم
بتصنيع السيارات منذ عام 1968.
الحلول التي تتجاوز مركبات الركاب
ودفع هذا المستقبل إلى الأمام
يقولون إنها استخدام الروبوتات الذكية
كشركة سيارات
نحن نفكر في السيارة المستقبلية التي
يمكننا تحقيق بعض التآزر القوي
بين هندسة السيارات
والتكنولوجيا الروبوتية
في عام 2021 ، استحوذت هيونداي على
شركة الروبوتات في ماساتشوستس
بوسطن  ديناميات الشركة
اشتهرت ببقعة الكلب الآلي ذات الأربع أرجل
والتي يمكنها مسح مناورة محيطها
عبر بيئات مختلفة وحتى
ديناميكيات بوسطن للرقص سلطت الضوء على روبوتين جديدين
يمتدان روبوتًا مصممًا
خصيصًا لرفع الأحمال الثقيلة
والمستودعات وأطلس روبوت للبحث
والتطوير يستكشف
حدود  قدرة الروبوت على التنقل ويمكنه
التحرك بطريقة مشابهة للبشر ،
فنحن جميعًا نتحدث عن الروبوتات وذكاء الروبوت ،
لقد بدأت ديناميكيات بوسطن
حقًا كشركة تنقل
وركزنا لسنوات عديدة على
مشكلة صنع روبوت يمكنه الذهاب إلى
أي مكان
وفي أي مكان يمكن  اليوم يشمل
عوالم افتراضية ، كما كشفت هيونداي النقاب
عن مفهوم التنقل الفوقي
الذي يقولون إنه يجلب الروبوتات إلى
metaverse
إذا كنت تريد أن تكون في
مكانين في وقت واحد يقولون إنه من
الممكن بمعنى أن
تسمح التكنولوجيا  أن يكون المستخدم متمركزًا في
مكان ما بينما يسمح الروبوت له
بالتواجد فعليًا في
[موسيقى] أخرى ،
تكون الروبوتات الخاصة بنا  ng يستخدمه العديد من
عملائنا لبناء توائم رقمية بحيث يقومون
بتركيب الماسحات الضوئية على الروبوت الذي يقوم بعد ذلك
بمسح بيئة وإنشاء نموذج
ثم استخدامه في تطبيقات نوع metaverse